Transcriber: Nermin Alhadad
المدقّق: gaith Takrity
يقول ألبرت آينشتاين “التعلم
المدرسي يجلب لك وظيفة
أما التعلم الذاتي يجلب لك عقلاً”
سمعنا كثيراً جملة “ابقوا في منازلكم”
في كل خطاب يظهرون فيه على التلفاز
قبل سنتين،
كنت في الصف الرابع وكانت الحياة
طبيعية وكل شيء طبيعي .
فجأةً، ظهر مرض خطير
هو كوفيد-١٩
غيّر كل شيء. أغلقَ كل شيء.
المحلات التجارية والأماكن العامة
حتى وصل الموضوع إلى إغلاق المدراس
رغم أني طالبة مجتهدة ومتفوقة
وأحب الدراسة كثيراً،
لكني فرحت كثيراً بالعطلة وبأنني سأرتاح
من الدراسة والمدرسة والامتحانات
أخذت بالتراجع وترك المواد
ولم أعد أدرس والتهيت باللعب لأنه الشيء
الوحيد
الذي يجعلني سعيدة في المنزل
وبعد فترة قررت وزارة التربية والتعليم
التوجه للتعليم عن بعد بدلاً عن الوجاهي
وهنا بدأت معاناتي ومأساتي
بعد ما كان اعتمادي على شرح معلماتي
ومساعدة ماما لي في فيلم المواد
ومن أول يوم في التعليم الإلكتروني
صرت أنادي ماما
وأقول لها: “ماما، تعالي اعمليلي انضمام”
“ماما، تعالي ارفقيلي الواجب”
وكل شي “ماما تعالي”
في يوم من الأيام كان عندي حصة مهمة
وفي اليوم التالي لدي امتحان بها
وماما مشغولة في الأعمال المنزلية.
وفجأة ينقطع النت
صرت أبكي
كيف سأكمل الحصة، كيف سأفهم المادة
كيف سأستوعب شيء جديد علي،
ماما قالت لي: “سوار، لا تبكي”
“وحاولي أن تبحثي عالنت،
وحاولي أن تساعدي نفسك”
أبحث عن النت! أساعد نفسي!
صرت أبحث عن الموضوع في اليوتيوب
بدأت أفهمه بالتدريج حتى أتى اليوم التالي
وقدمت الامتحان
وحصلت على العلامة الكاملة
هنا اكتشفت أني أستطيع الاعتماد على نفسي
ولا يوجد داعي للاعتمد على ماما
في برنامج Team، وبرامج التعليم عن بعد
صرت احضر فيديوهات
عن طريقة استخدام البرنامج
اول يوم، بعض من الوقت
تاني يوم نفس الشيء
الموضوع لم يأخذ معي الكثير من الوقت
في ظرف كم يوم فهمت وتعلمت
كنت كلما أحضر فيديو وأبحث،
أتشجع أن أحضر فيديو آخر
وأن أزيد معلوماتي عنه
لدرجة أنني صرت أساعد أخي الصغير فيه
وأعلمه كيفية استخدامه،
في أثناء البحث تعرفت على برامج لنفس المجال
مثل برنامج Zoom و Meet
هنا اكتشفت شيء اسمه “التعلم الذاتي”
هذا جعلني أضع خطة لتطوير نفسي
عن طريق عدة وسائل
وضعت خطة للتعلم، وماذا أريد أن أتعلم
ووضعت خطة وزمن محدد عشان أنا التزم فيها
ولم يكن اعتمادي فقط على المنهاج ومعلماته
أصبحت أبحث بعمق أكثر ففي العلوم
تعرفت على الفضاء
وفي الرياضيات تعلمت المعادلات والأسس
وفي العربية تعلمت تاريخ
اللغة العربية
واستمريت على هذا الحال طول فترة الإغلاق
وفترة توجهنا للتعلم عن بعد
وبعد ما عدنا للمدرسة عممت تجربتي
على طلاب المدرسة
من خلال الإذاعة المدرسية،
وساعدتني إدارة المدرسة ومعلمة الحاسوب
من خلال حصة البرمجة والتكنولوجيا
على تحفيز الطلاب
ومساعدتهم في التعلم الذاتي
اهتم الكثير من الباحثين بالتعلم الذاتي
باعتباره أسلوب ملائم للمتعلم
ويتناسب مع قدراته وسرعته الذاتية
ودافعيته للتعلم
وأظهرت نتائج البحوث أهمية التعلم الذاتي
الذي يعزز الاستقلالية والثقة في النفس
فلولا التعلم الذاتي لما كنت بهذه الثقة
أتحدث أمامكم
إن التعلم الذاتي
يواجه عالميا مشكلة الملل
أو عدم القدرة على التواصل
بسبب عدم توفر التحفيز الخارجي
فعادةً لازم نحرص على التحفيز في التعلم .
وفي التعلم الذاتي
لازم نحرص على التحفيز الداخلي
وذلك من خلال تزويد الشخص لنفسه
بمكافآت ومشجعات
وكنت أكافئ نفسي بكل مرة أتعلم بها بمحفز
وأريد أن أقول لكم:
لا تدعو شيء يقف عند عمر معين
أو وقت معين أو حدث معين
إذا كنت صغيرة هذا لا يعني
أني لا أستطيع التعلّم أو التعليم
ومن خلال التطبيق النظري والعملي
للتعلم الذاتي
أستطيع أن أنقل تجربتي للآخرين
بتخصيص حصة أو وقت معين لتعريف الطلبة
وخاصة الأطفال الصغار على البرامج التعليمية
والتطبيقات الإلكترونية التعليمية
وتدريبهم بالذات على استخدامها
وأن نعمل في مجموعات شبابية
في جمعيات ومؤسسات
من خلال شباب متطوعين فيها
يمكن من خلالهم إيصال الفكرة للعالم
أريد أن أخبركم بسر:
حتى تتوظف بسرعة ونقلل من نسبة البطالة
شركة غوغل وأبل و12 شركة أمريكية ثانية
يوظفون الناس على أساس
المهارات المكتسبة في التعلم الذاتي وليس
على أساس الشهادات الجامعية فقط
ومن هنا أريد تقديم هذه النصيحة لكم:
غذوا أنفسكم بالتعلم
خذوا بالتعلم عن كل ما هو حولكم
لتشبعوها بالثقة والمعرفة
فلتبدأوا من الآن
وتستغلوا كل دقيقة.
وشكرا.
(تصفيق)